Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du ist alles ein bisschen fragwürdig. Der Erste, der leidet unter Kleingeldverbot, sind Obdachlose. Ja, dann soll man denen diese EC-Karten-Slots geben. Einfach vor sich, ähnlich verranzt und selbstgebaut wirkend, einfach so einen Schlitz vorne hinstellen, wo man einfach eine EC-Karte durchzieht und einen Euro eingibt und dann ist er gut. So ein Pattern-Ding. Ich wurde letztens am Hauptbahnhof verarscht, kennen die meisten jetzt schon aus meinem Moin Moin, aber hat jemand gesagt, er will eine Fahrkarte kaufen, aber war unangenehm, ich habe jetzt tatsächlich mein Vertrauen in die Menschheit verloren. Warum gibst du jemandem 20 Euro? Weil er gesagt hat, er hat ein Vorstellungsgespräch in Essen und will da hinfahren und braucht 20 Euro. Und dann habe ich ihm 20 Euro gegeben und hat gesagt, nein, er braucht jetzt aber auch noch ein Ticket für seine Cousine und will 40 Euro. Und er hat gesagt, nee, so viel nicht. Und ich glaube, sein ganzer Trick war, dass er möglichst verhindern wollte, dass er schon in den Automaten geworfen wird. Weil er stand am Automaten und egal,
egal, egal. Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt,
schaut euch mal in meinen Moin Moin.
Auf jeden Fall. Bleibt diesen Podcast frei. Ne, ne, auch nö. Hier gibt es auch
gute Sachen. Auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt mein
Vertrauen in die Menschheit verloren. Menschen sind
schlechte Wesen, die
die guten Qualitäten von anderen Menschen ausnutzen,
wie du, der hier schönen Schoko,
Keks und Cookie Crumble schnabulierst hier gerade. Ich verstehe dich nicht mehr. Ich habe mir extra mal so einen Snack-Buffet hier aufgebaut. Jaffa-Cake, Pflaume, schön Weihnachtseite, Pflaume. Warum ist Pflaume Weihnachten? Was hat Pflaume mit Weihnachten zu tun? Dann hier so schöne Weihnachtskookies. Und du kannst das alles nicht essen, du nimmst aber auch nicht ab durch deine vegane Scheiße. Heißt, du hast einfach irgendwann entschieden, ja, soll ich mal ein bisschen schlechter leben? Ja. Das Leben darf nicht zu gut sein. Wenn du immer am Limit bist, dann hast du nichts, worauf du dich freuen kannst. Doch, neue Limits. Was war das letzte Limit, das du durchbrochen hast, Stefan Tee? Mein letztes Limit, ich durchbrochen habe, erste Klasse-Ticket. Einfach mal schön, erste Klasse-Ticket in der Bahn. Das ist ein bisschen besser, neues Limit. Und dann ist das Problem, du musst finanziell mit deinen Limits aber auch mithalten können, irgendwann musst du halt aufstocken finanziell, damit du immer neue Limits erreichen kannst. Das ist nichts für Obdachlose oder arme Leute. Arme Leute, die können nicht immer neue Limits sich setzen. Kennst du die Z-Skala? Die Z-Skala sortiert Podcasts nach der Dauer, die es braucht, von Podcast-Anfang bis zum ersten ICE-Zugreferenz. Wirklich? Wir sind momentan auf Platz vier der Z-Skala. Ganz kurz, was ist Platz, was heißt das, heißt das, bei uns kommt es schnell oder bei uns kommt es langsam? Bei uns kommt es schon ziemlich schnell, aber es gibt drei Podcasts, wo es schnell läuft. Selbst Gäste des Geisterbahn, die in einem Zug aufgenommen haben, sind auf Platz sechs. Also wir müssen uns ein bisschen ranhalten, aber es ist eine spannende Statistik. Wir verbringen halt, erzählen meine U-Bahn-Stories auch dazu? Nein. Nee? Nein. Dann bist du schuld, definitiv, weil du die meisten halt im ICE verbringst und immer erzählst die Story zu erzählen. Richtig, herzlich willkommen beim Podcast UFO. Ihr habt das schon gemerkt, Stefan Tietz ist immer im Haus. Wir sind mal wieder abgeschoben worden, so ein bisschen. Wir sind in einem falschen Raum, es klingt ein bisschen Hall, Hall, Hall. Wir sind im Massenraum, Stefan trägt eine lustige Perücke.
Er hat nur sehr oft Hall gesagt, falls ihr euch fragt, boah, das war echt ein krasses Echo jetzt, nee, er hat nur ein paar Mal gesagt. Naja, Stefan hat eine lustige Perücke auf, er hat sich diese Nadeln auch in die Kopfhaut gedrückt. Das ist nicht, das ist keine Perücke, das ist meine neue Frisur, danke, dass es dir aufgefallen ist, das ist der Wintertrend für mich heute. Ich dachte mal, Friseurgehen ist so eine Sache, man will auch, ich habe immer den Angst, ich will jetzt eigentlich ganz, ganz so einen Friseur und ich will meine Haare länger wachsen lassen. Das ist mein Ziel. Ich weiß nicht, woher das Ziel kommt, aus irgendeinem ästhetischen Bewusstsein, keine Ahnung. Ich will einfach auf meinem Oben, der Pony soll länger sein und der soll zu mir ins Gesicht fallen. Dir ist schon klar, dass du nicht zum Friseur gehen kannst und sagen kannst, hallo, ich hätte gerne längere Haare. Eben, und genau das klingt jetzt erstmal wie ein lustiges Problem, haha, wenn ihr gesagt habt, lustiger Gag von Florentin. Aber so einfach ist das nicht, so einfach kommt es mir nicht davon. Denn natürlich muss es die ganze Zeit geschnitten werden, hinten die Haare müssen in Form gebracht werden, die Seiten müssen geschnitten werden, hinten muss geschnitten werden. Es kann nicht alles gleichmäßig länger werden, das sieht scheiße aus. Also du möchtest jetzt kontrolliert deine Haare länger wachsen lassen. Ja! Und wie sagt man das? Ist das die nächste Stefan-Phase? Und wie sagt man das? Nein, aber das ist glaube ich keine Phase. Ich glaube nicht, dass es einige Stunden meines Tages einnimmt, diese Phase, aber vielleicht ist es eine Phase, aber ich muss auf jeden Fall zum Friseur gehen und dem sagen, ähm, sagen Sie mir, was ich tun soll, damit meine Haare wachsen, ohne dass es zwischendurch scheiße aussieht. Hast du schon mal gehadbangt? Ähm, nee. Ich hab's versucht ... Du hast noch nie gehadbangt. Ich will das nicht so sagen, weil das bestimmt hab ich schon mal gehadbangt. Bestimmt hab ich schon mal in meinem Zimmer gesessen. So richtig Hände auf Knie, ein bisschen in die Hocke und so richtig den Kopf gebankt. Vor allem, das ist schon lustig, diese Hand-auf-Knie-Geste. Ja. H auf K. Dieses It's getting serious. Ja, ist schon so was wie, jetzt geht's los, das ist jetzt kein Hobby mehr, das ist schon mehr als das. Und vor allem, ich habe jetzt auch vor, eine Weile zu bangen. Das ist jetzt nicht nur so, ich meine, gut, wie lange hältst du in der Regel denselben Tanzschritt? Oh, lange. Schöne Disse, wirklich? Ja, ich habe nur einen. Aber sag mal ungefähr eine Zeitangabe. Weil man ist ja so, also man ist ja schön der Disse im Club, im Q-Club, in München, irgendwie Kufa, Kulturfabrik, irgendwie mal schön nzzz nzzz. Gott, wie viele Abkürzungen herauskommen. Ballert einfach mal. Und dann ist noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, du machst gerade irgendwie den schönen Raise-the-Roof-Move, wo du so die Hände mit flachen, flachen Hände so nach oben pumpst. Wie lange macht man den? Und man denkt sich nach vier Sekunden, ich muss mir jetzt was anderes ausdenken. Aber wie lange hältst du so einen Move durch? Was ist so bei dir die Frequenz? Ich habe nur einen Move und deswegen kann ich solide sagen vier Stunden. Vier Stunden pro Move? Einfach vier Stunden mein, einen Move und der ist einfach nur linkes Bein nach links, rechtes Bein nach links, rechtes Bein nach rechts. Das nennt man Laufen, Stefan, davon rede ich jetzt nicht. Linkes Bein nach rechts. Und das die ganze Zeit, vielleicht manchmal schnipsen. Wo ich mir denke, ist schnipsen noch ein Ding? Ich weiß es doch auch immer nicht. Du kannst in einem Club nicht schnipsen, das geht nicht. Ich hätte gerne Selbstbewusstsein. Ich finde, je höher die Hände waren beim Tanzen, desto mehr Selbstbewusstsein hat man. Interessante Theorie. Irgendwann kommen nämlich dann die Frauen, die mal so die Hände dann hochschmeissen und dann wirklich einfach die Hände ganz hochstrecken und dann sich so schlangenmässig tanzen. Das ist wirklich die grösste Art zu tanzen. Oder auch ein Klassiktänzer, der die Arme hochnehmen, damit die Frau unten durch kann. Du meinst den Dirigenten mit Klassiktänzer. Im Grunde ist Tanzen eine Antwort auf die Frage, wohin mit?
Und jedes Körperteile hat eine andere Antwort.
Wohin mit den Schultern, wohin mit dem Bauch?
Und dein Schnipsen ist halt eine Frage auf, wohin mit den Fingern?
Das ist eine berechtigte Frage.
Wohin mit den Händen?
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist ja, sobald die Frage aufkommt, machst du es eigentlich schon falsch.
Wenn du dir fragst, wohin mit meinem Arm, ist es eigentlich schon falsch.
Aber jeder beantwortet die Frage auf seine eigene Weise.
Manche Promis haben, wohin mit meinem Penis, ein bisschen falsch beantwortet in letzter Zeit, würde ich sagen. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Satire-Vorcast. Mit der feinen Klinge der Satire greifen wir an und filetieren die Kulturlandschaft. Es ist ein Satire-Filet, Satire-Filet. Kenntest du diese Käse-Dinger, wo man den Käse so von oben so abkurbelt? Ja. Das ist auch, glaube ich, so ein Weihnachts- und Feiertagsding. Das ist nur eine Käse-Reibe? Nein, aber es gibt so Sachen, die man einfach mal auspackt. Ich habe ja letztens schon geredet von Zimt, dass irgendwie allein die Tatsache, dass es Feiertage gibt, sorgt dafür, dass die Feiertage noch besonderer werden, weil man alles, was man sich nur manchmal leisten kann, dann eine Feiertage macht. Da siehst du an Pfingsten, da siehst du an Frohen Leichenabend. Fondue zum Beispiel. Fondue ist verrückt, aber du sagst, mein Gott, wir machen es nur an einem Tag. Wenn ich nach Hause komme, meinen Pokémon-Rucksack in die Ecke werfe, dein Fondue-Kessel raus und meine Mama sagt, hey, ich habe Fondue gemacht, sage ich, Stopp! Halt die Fresse, du F... Ey, apropos, ich muss ganz kurz was raussuchen, weil es unfassbar ist. Ganz kurz, füll mal. Ja, okay, ich weiß ungefähr, worum es geht. Aber das stimmt, du hast natürlich recht. Wir haben vor zwei Wochen abends gerackletet am Wochenende. Du hast alleine gerackletet? Nein. Nein, okay, ich dachte ... Aber das ist schon interessant, weil mitten im Jahr kommt einem das komisch vor. Das ist ein typisches Silvester-Ding. Und einfach dieses Auspacken, dieses aus dem Keller das Raclette-Gerät holen, was natürlich noch dreckig ist von vor einem Jahr, und dann anfangen, das sauber zu machen und so. Das ist schon ein bisschen, das fühlt sich falsch an im Mitten des Jahres. Aber warst du denn jetzt schon geracletet? Ja, weiß ich nicht, da war so eine Stimmung. Du bist ungeduldig. Ja, ein bisschen ungeduldig. Kannst nicht erwarten. Vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen vorheilig. Aber Rackle ist ja auch was, was schade ist, dass es nur einmal im Jahr ist. Etwas mit Käse zu überbacken, ist ja jetzt per se nichts Schlechtes. Der traurigste Anblick ist auch immer, wenn du jeden Morgen hier zum Büro kommst und Stefan kommt und kratzt seinen Schlitten über den Asphalt und mit seinem Schale und seiner Mütze. Und man denkt sich, Stefan, es hat noch nicht geschneit, es ist zu früh, aber er immer mit Tränen in den Augen kratzt über den Asphalt. Auch schon Ende Januar mit seinem Tanktop hier am Tanktop und Surfbrett hier am Hof steht, wo man denkt, Surfen würde auch bei richtigen Wetter keinen Sinn ergeben. Irgendwann hast du den Rhythmus einfach verloren, bei dir hat sich das Jahr einfach mal nach vorne, ich glaube, das war dein Urlaub hier auf den Malediven, dadurch hat sich dein Jahr verschoben. Ich bin jetzt müde, Ich könnte jetzt ins Bett gehen und würde durchschlafen. Das ist immer noch, ich bin immer in einer Zeitzone gefangen. Im Kopf sehe ich immer noch die Rochen vor mir her schwimmen. Machen wir jetzt ein Video an. Also, es gibt einen neuen Pokémon-Film, weil ich gerade Pokémon gesagt habe, ich finde es unglaublich. Es gibt einen neuen Pokémon-Film und der wurde in einem Test-Screening geheim gezeigt vor ausgewählten Publikum.
Und da hat jemand mitgefilmt, und zwar ist dort folgende interessante Szene passiert.
Wir haben eine hochemotionale Szene zwischen Ash Ketchum und seinem Lieblings-Pokémon Pikachu.
Und was dort passiert ist, da hören wir jetzt mal ganz kurz rein.
Das ist professionell eingespielt. Es ist eine Szene, in der Pikachu spricht.
Pikachu fängt an zu sprechen und die Leute können nicht mehr an sich halten. Die Leute können das nochmal zeigen.
Der Moment, wo er anfängt zu sprechen.
Ja, nochmal rein. Pikachu, why won't you get a little more Pokemon? It's because... What the fuck? What the fuck? Why not? No! That's not it! Der eine Mann, der ein bisschen zu spät sagt, no! Weil ich mir denke, was hat der da vor, während alle schon ihren Unmut kundgetan haben. Einfach Fassungslosigkeit. What the fuck is happening? Und dann wieder ein Mann, der so spät kommt, no! Er kann es einfach so leiden. Aber wie lustig ist das, es gibt seit 20 Jahren Pokémon. Was eine dusselige Idee. Ein Punkt, aber auch die Reaktion, so hohen wir uns dann alle so What, what the fuck plötzlich. Aber auch wirklich dann die
einfach, was ist eine doofe Idee, mit Anlauf
eine dumme Idee reingeschaut. Ja, jeder
weiß, dass das dumm ist. Ich glaube, es gibt
immer so lustige Filme, in denen Tiere reden
können und alle immer so, oh mein Gott,
unser Hund redet. Ich glaube, man würde exakt
so reagieren, so
What the fuck
No! Und einfach draufschlagen.
Aber ich finde, what the fuck ist sowieso die beste Reaktion auf alles. Ich kann mich erinnern, wir waren Abifahrt, wir waren in Kroatien am Strand irgendwie schön, irgendwie saufen, trinken, Flüssigkeit und da gab es eine Szene, dass wir so, ein Freund von mir und ich, wir waren in so einem Bungalow, dann gab es so Bungalows immer so Sechsergruppen und wir waren leider so ein bisschen die Trottel und wir waren so die Reste. Es gibt ja immer so, immer wenn so Schülergruppen, so Klassen aufgeteilt werden auf Zimmern, es gibt die Restmenschen. und hat er noch platz für florentin es ist wirklich so dein gesamtes schulleben du kannst
dich eigentlich am ersten schultag hinsetzen und anfangen zu beten, bitte, bitte, lass mich niemals unter den Restmännchen sein.
Man könnte auch was dafür tun, dass man aktiv cooler wird, aber das ist vorhin von Persi abgelehnt. Ich habe mein Schicksal im Gebet gesucht.
Aber es ist wirklich, und ich hatte tatsächlich immer das Glück, nie zu den Restmenschen gehören, ausser eine Abifahrt beim letzten Mal.
Es war immer schon so oft ganz wichtig, die Fahrt ins Schullandheim.
Wo sitzt du im Bus? Glück nie zu den Restmännchen gehören, ausser eine Abifahrt beim letzten Mal. Es war immer schon so oft ganz
wichtig, die Fahrt ins Schullandheim.
Wo sitzt du im Bus? Weil im
Bus werden schon die Zimmer entschieden.
Bus ist Krieg.
Hinten sind die ganz Coolen,
vorne sitzen auch noch mal die Coolen,
es sei denn Lehrer. Manchmal sind Lehrer
vorne beim Busfahrer und dann ist auch
die erste Reihe noch ganz cool.
In keiner Situation werden soziale Kompetenzen so heiß und gnadenlos geschmiedet, wie in der Schulzeit bei Schullandheim. Wenn du dann irgendwie so eine Fünfer-Freunde-Gruppe bist und so, ah geil, wir kommen in ein Zimmer, alter, geil, mega, oh, wer schläft oben, wer schläft unten, ja, es sind immer vier Personen pro Zimmer. Und man guckt sich in seiner Fünfer-Gruppe an und denkt sich, und das ist reines Überleben. Alle wissen schon, Florentin wird rausfliegen. Ey, das ist reines Überleben. Die überlegen nur noch, wie sagen wir es ihm und er weiß noch nicht von seinem Schicksal. Ey, das ist so ein Drama. Das ist wie wenn du in so einem Boot sitzt zu fünft, irgendwie nach dem Schiffbruch und du weißt, einer wird gegessen. Oder es ist wie in einem Heisshoffballon, wo alle merken, scheiße, wir rasen auf dem Boden zu, der Lava ist. Und wir müssen einen rauswerfen, damit wir wieder steigen. Wer ist es? Ja, der Dickste. Na gut. Oder auch eine Person würde reichen, das hat für die Präbisse jetzt nicht mehr gerecht, aber eine Person würde reichen, die man los will. Ja, auf jeden Fall, wir waren in dem Resterraum. Das ist dann so, wenn die Reste aus, es gibt ja so Klicken in der Klasse, und jede Clique hat seine Reste, und alle Reste kommen in diesem einen, wie beim Toaster, wo unten so die Krümel aufgefangen werden, in dieser Schublade, die ekelhaft ist. Ein neues Toast bilden kann. Genau, den man zusammendrückt. Und genauso war dieses eine Bungalow, wo wir waren und wir waren zu zweit in einem Bett. Und der Rest von der Kifferbande, der Rest von den Kuhlmädchen. Ja, die Nerds waren da, genau. Der Rest von den Nerds. Diese Gruppe hat nichts gemein miteinander. Vor allem die unattraktivste von der Gruppe der attraktiven Mädchen. Die hatten wir bei uns im Bungalow. Immer noch wesentlich attraktiver als alles, was wir jemals gesprochen haben. Aber man denkt sich, na, auf jeden Fall wurden wir dann irgendwann mal geprankt von einem anderen Bungalow. Von den coolen. Von den coolen. Den Prankern. Und der Prank bestand daraus, dass mitten in der Nacht erstmal wurde... Ein Feuer gelegt wurde. Und es war einfach aller weggebrannt. Also erstmal, vor allem es war ein Doppelprank und ich fand den subtilen Prank viel lustiger als den echten Prank. Und der harte Prank war, dass sie mitten in der Nacht, wie ich um vier Uhr nachts so tief geschlafen habe, ist einer von den Prankstern in unser Zimmer gestürmt mit einem Besen und hat uns den Besen ins Gesicht gebest, während wir geschlafen haben einfach und hat mit dem Besen ins Gesicht geraten, einfach gnadenlos. Wie sieht das Brainstorming aus? Vor allem, er muss ja erst mal in eine Art Abstellkammer gegangen sein.
Allein das nachts zu machen, wo man ja nicht viel riskieren will,
das für so eine gute Idee zu halten, dass sie dafür in einen anderen Raum gehen, um den Besen zu nehmen, das einzige Mittel, mit dem sie euch ins Gesicht schlagen können? Was waren die anderen Ideen, die verworfen wurden und sagen, nee, nee, wir machen den Besen, Alter. Ich glaube, es gab nur zwei Alternativen. Das Zimmer anstecken war eine davon.
Es war nicht einmal ein Scherz gemeint,
aber diese Gruppe hätte auch das sein können.
Auf jeden Fall, es hat jetzt nicht mich getroffen,
sondern mein Freund, der neben mir geschlafen hat.
Und er wurde halt schön ins Gesicht gebest
und wacht auf und man denkt sich wirklich,
für den Schlafenden ist das jetzt wirklich
eine Situation zwischen Leben und Tod.
Du schläfst in deinem Haus,
Nacht, ein Eindringling greift dich mit einer Waffe an und er hat wirklich genauso reagiert wie bei Pikachu, so einem What the fuck, Alter, what? Und genauso reagiert. Wo ich immer denke, genauso würde man reagieren, wenn jemand nachts mit einer Pistole sitzt und du so What the fuck, Alter, was geht? Alter, Alter, Alter, ich glaube, das ist Alter, A, L, D, A. Leute, wow, way! Man neigt zum D, man neigt in Horrorsituationen zum D. Ja, ganz interessante Beobachtung. Alter, Leute, Leute, was geht denn hier? Aber ausser mich, du wachst in der Nacht auf, Rauch in deiner Nase, das Kind schreit und du, Leute, Leute, hey, what the? Und genau so hat er reagiert und der zweite subtile Prank, dass sie unsere Schuhe in den Kühlschrank getan haben. Danke! Das ist ein guter Prank. Schuhe in den Kühlschrank ist ein guter Prank, weil du wachst auf, du suchst deine Schuhe, du findest deine Schuhe nicht, du setzt dich, machst Frühstück und du siehst, ah, meine Schuhe waren im Kühlschrank die ganze Zeit, dann ziehst du dir deine Schuhe an, deine Füße sind kalt, haha, niemandem wird wirklich ernsthaft geschadet, aber man denkt sich lustig. Das ist ein guter Prank. Jetzt frage ich mich noch einmal, wie das Brainstorming aussah. Diese kleine Idee von Timo, der zwischendurch ein bisschen zu leise geäußert hat, dass sein Kumpel den Lauten nochmal wiederholen musste, er hat gesagt, wir wollen die Stube vielleicht in den Kühlschrank kommen. Dass diese Idee es auch noch geschafft hat, irgendwie umgesetzt zu werden.
Weil er gesagt hat, wir sind schon für die Besen-Idee, aber das mit dem Kühlschrank, das könnt ihr doch nebenbei irgendwie machen.
Die wollten eine gute Diskussion geben. Komische Sache. Strange Sache.
Also, ich wurde mal ein Opfer beim Fussballverein, da hat man mein Handtuch draus gemacht.
Oh nein.
Wo man auch dachte, wow, das ist schon, ja, es ist nicht wirklich lustig, aber es ist schon ziemlich on point gemein. Weil ich kann mich, jetzt bin ich nass. Aber nachdem du geduscht hast. Ja. Und dann musstest du mit dem nassen Handtuch nach Hause laufen. Ja, genau. Guter Freund von mir, mit dem ich da in dem Bungalow war. Am ersten Tag hat er seinen Geldbeutel verloren. Und die gesamte Woche Studienabifahrt hatte er damit zu tun, Stress zu haben wegen, er hatte kein Geld mehr, er musste sich ständig Geld leihen, was mega unangenehm ist. Weil du kannst dir bei jedem Menschen nur einen gewissen Betrag leihen. Niemand, kein Schüler, kein Abischüler leitet dir mehr als 50 Euro einfach so. Das heißt, er musste ständig zu anderen Leuten gehen, sich Geld leihen, dann bei dem, dann musste er immer Buch führen, und dann wollte er sich was kaufen, aber dann musste er sich wieder was leihen. Dann musste er Buch führen. Du musst dir jede Ausgabe überlegen, weil du immer denkst, okay, will ich jetzt noch die Chivap-Chi-Chi mir holen, dann muss ich wieder drei Euro beim Stefan leihen, wo ist der jetzt, ist der beim Strand? Was hat der Kostet in Kroatien? Gar nichts, irgendwas. Ja. Es ist lächerlich günstig da. Und dann am ersten Tag waren wir irgendwie baden und da hat er seinen Geldbeutel voll und er hat ihn überall gesucht und er hat alle gefragt, hast du vielleicht mein Geldbeutel? Und die gesamte Woche, alle waren genervt, die gesamte Woche hat er wirklich gelitten und am letzten Tag hat einer, mit dem er beim Baden war, gesagt so, in meinem Rucksack ist noch dein Geldbeutel, muss ich wohl eingepackt haben. Ciao, wir sehen uns nie wieder in unserem Leben. Und er nur so, das ist nicht dein fucking Ernst. Das ist scheiße. Wo er einfach denkt so, nee, du hast einfach verloren. Aber es gab immer diesen einenjenigen, den Schlüsselverlangen, wo die ganze Fahrt ist dann gelaufen. Und wenn du dann der bist, mit der meistens Zeit wird mit ihm verbringt, dann ist dein Urlaub auch mitgelaufen. Du hast jetzt den Urlaub versaut, vielen Dank auch. Aber der hat ja noch ein Besitziges. Ach, deswegen kein Bargeld. Nee, das ist die Lektion, die du daraus ziehst, kein Bargeld? Also, oder keine fremden Portemonnaies einstecken. Ich will nicht so gute Lektionen ausziehen. Und dann hat auch so, ruft man bei der Bank an und lässt man jetzt seine Geldkarte, seine Winnie-Poo-Geldkarte, die man seit ab, seitdem lässt man die jetzt sperren, weil da sind noch drei Euro sechzig drauf, weil man unter fünf Euro die nicht abheben kann. So lässt man die sperren, gibt man seinen Eltern Bescheid? Sorry, kann ich meine Winnie-Pooh-Karte sperren? Nee, geht gar nicht, ist nicht dafür gemacht. Nee. 1-1-6-1-1-6, die Hotline für Kartensperren. Drei, fünft, sieben, sechs, acht, 357-680-169, meine ICQ-Nummer. Nicht schlecht, du editest Stefan auf Wiu, Wiu. Nee, wie war das? Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Die Spiele auf ICQ. Ja, das war krass, ne? Und was hast du sonst noch so die Woche erlebt, was bist du umgekommen? Außer, dass du den Entschluss gefasst hast, dass du lange Haare haben möchtest. Ja, guck mal. Wie kam es dazu? Ne, ich war, ich war, ähm, am Montag in Berlin war ich auf einer Premiere, äh, und das war... Wow! Ne, ich will da gar nicht ins Detail gehen, nein, da war das auch gar nicht gemeint, bin ich zufällig gelandet. Wow! Hey! Hey! Stefan! Wir springen 20 Minuten in die Zukunft. Hey! Es ist zu dem Moment gekommen, wo ich dann leider gespoilert wurde. Und zwar, es war eine Serie. So, und dann hat man halt die erste Folge geguckt. Und dann ging es in der ganzen Serie so ein bisschen darum, wer ist der Vater von wem. Und es hat Generationen und Zeitachsen gespielt und so weiter. Und dann war ich nach der Premiere auf dem Klo und dann war ein kleiner Junge da, der mitgespielt hat. Und das fand ich schon ein bisschen verwirrend. Oh cool, der hat mitgespielt und dann kam ein anderer Junge. Du warst auf dem selben Klo mit dem Hauptdarsteller dieser erfolgreichen Serie. Ja, das war ein grosses Klo, ein Kinoklo.
Und dann kam ein anderer Junge da hinzu.
Und der hat so gefragt wie, ah, du warst ja da von eben. Ja, richtig, du hast auch mitgespielt. Ja, ja, hab ich auch mitgespielt. Ich bin der Vater von Ulrich. Und ich so, what? Ah, nein. Aus einer Kabine hört man, what the? Es war exakt so. Ich war in der Kabine, die waren in der Kabine, oder draußen gerade, haben gesprochen miteinander und dann dachte ich mir so, was?
Das kann doch jetzt nicht wahr sein und dann hat er einfach so Folge 8 oder so gespoilert.
Das ist interessant, das ist immer schwer. Bei Seven
gab es zum Beispiel auch das Problem, dass
bei den ersten Credits, wo die Namen
genannt wurden, wurde Kevin Spacey nicht genannt,
weil sonst jeder mehr oder weniger weiss,
Kevin Spacey ist der Mörder, weil er spielt eine große Rolle.
Alle sitzen bis zum Ende da, wo ist Kevin Spacey,
wo ist Kevin Spacey? Deswegen war am Ende, weil er spielt eine große Rolle. Alle sitzen bis zum Ende da, wo ist Kevin Spacey, wo ist Kevin Spacey?
Deswegen war am Ende der erste Name, der dann genannt wurde. Am Ende, am Abschlussabspann, da gab es noch mal ganz langen Abspann. Ja, da gibt es mal lange Abspann. Am Ende eines Films. Da kann man noch mal sehen, wer alles mitgemacht hat. Ich habe Justice League gesehen, unfassbar. ich versuche mal die
Abspannseiten zu zählen,
die die Special-Effekts-Leute machen. Halt einfach, wenn man sich vorstellt, eine Leinwand ist eine Seite ungefähr. Wie viele Seiten, dicht bedruckte Leute haben Special-Effekts gemacht. Ich glaube, es waren drei mit jeweils vier Namen pro Reihe. Einfach unfassbar viele Namen. Das ist immer unglaublich. Das beste Effekt ist diese gesichtslosen Heerscharen, die dann einfach da immer die Schnurrbartbärte wegmachen von den Leuten. Ja, tatsächlich war es ja so bei Justice League, dass der Hauptdarsteller, der Superman, hatte eigentlich einen Schnurrbart zur Zeit, weil er halt noch einen anderen Film gedreht hat. Und da mussten die wirklich tagelang, sass da ein armer Mann, der dann den Stuhlwatt weggemacht hat, wegretuschiert hat mit so einer Groardiergummi-Funktion. Was auch nervig. Das ist, weil vor allem ist es ja, man stellt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich so vor, so Special Effects-Artists oder so, geil, hier Staub, Feuer, Explosion, oh cool, die springt rein und oh, kann man erkennen, dass es nicht die echte Jennifer Lawrence ist, nein. Aber ich glaube, deren Arbeit ist brutalst kleinteilig. Ja, ja, Frame for frame. Erstens nicht das, aber die machen, glaube ich, auch immer genau dasselbe. Das ist halt wie Akkordarbeit, wie irgendwie bei VW, wo einer immer dieselbe Schraube reindrückt. So bei Hobbit zum Beispiel haben die da so dieses Special-Fact-Seite gesagt und einer hat gesagt so, ja, ich habe den gesamten Film eigentlich nur dafür gesorgt, dass die Hobbits genau so gross sind, wie die Hobbits gross sein sollen.
Ich habe die immer ein bisschen kleiner skaliert.
Und du hast wirklich in seinen Augen gesehen, dass der irgendwie nicht mehr Tränen und dass der einfach in der ersten Schublade einfach eine Pistole hat, mit der sich nach dem Interview das Gehirn rausbläst.
Es gibt auch so ein Video, wo die ganzen profillosen Drecks-Hobbits sich kurz alle vorstellen, die ganzen Schausauspieler, einer sagt so, ja. Zwerge meinst du, oder? Ja, tatsächlich meine ich die Zwerge. Und einer von den profillosen Scheiß-Drecks-Zwergen sagt dann sowas wie, ja, ich zähle das Geld. Und der andere sagt so, ja, und mein Charakter ist halt immer ein bisschen gierig. Und der andere sagt so, ja, mein Charakter hat ein bisschen Fußball in der Freizeit. Und dann sagt der eine, der hat dann, ja, meiner ist der fette Zwerg. Meiner ist er einfach der dicke Zwerg. Vor allem, es gibt sogar, weißt du, einer, der sagt, ja, ich bin für das Geld verantwortlich. Und dann gibt es in Hobbit 3, glaube ich, gibt es eine Szene, wo sie jemanden bezahlen müssen, der sie über das Ding bringt, wo sie diesen Fährmann kennenlernen. Und wer ist der Typ, der das Geld handelt? Nicht der, der dafür verantwortlich ist. Wenn dein Zwerg einen einzigen Satz als Persönlichkeit hat und dann nicht mal das macht im Fährmann. Wollt ihr uns eigentlich verarschen? Und der dicke Hobbit war in einer Szene nicht dick? Ja. Oh mein Gott! Der dicke Hobbit wurde gefragt, wollen Sie noch eine zweite Portion? Und er hat gesagt, nein, und nicht glaube, wofür zahle ich hier denn 16 Euro für 3D und 60 Frames, verdammt? Das ist echt so besch... 60 Frames kann man nicht mal sehen! Ich komm nicht hinterher, ich bin noch bei den ersten 10 Frames! Wie nehme ich das wahr? Muss ich mehr blinzeln? Muss ich nicht mehr blinzeln? Jetzt kommt ja die Herr der Ringe Serie bei Amazon. Es ist auch anstrengend einfach, wenn du die ganze Zeit da sitzt und dann musst du deine Augen so befeuchten, damit du irgendwann 120 Frames fahren kannst. Ich musste mir das Gesicht spucken während des Films, damit es funktioniert. Was ist ein Scheiß, Dreckserlebnis, stimmt, Serie. Ich glaube, machen Chameleons so, die machen mit ihrer Zunge ihre Augen feucht. Ich glaube, es ist ein Tier, ein Tier, die können sogar blinzeln. Nee, eben nicht. Nee, nee, erleben wir uns, wir können blinzeln. Es gibt irgendein anderes Tier. Es gibt, glaube ich, ein Tier, das hat diesen Blinzel-Ding nicht drauf, das checkt es einfach nicht und macht es mit der Zunge. Das macht dann immer so, ne, und macht dann immer rechts das Auge, linkes Auge. Chameleon sind cool, wenn man irgendwann entdeckt hat, dass die alles greifen. Das hast du schon mal erzählt. Das ist faszinierend. Die Herr der Ringe Amazon-Serie kommt bald. Es soll um die Geschichte vor den Filmen gehen, vor Herr der Ringe. Das heißt, es wird richtig spannend. Ich freue mich. Du bist ja in einem anderen Moderation, es müsste eigentlich so ein Einspieler kommen,
wo wir mal reingeguckt, wenn wir mit dem Produzenten gesprochen haben.
Und das erste Screening von der Herr-der fallen und die Leinwand zerbricht so. No! Oh mein, die Figuren, die alle dafür lieben, dass sie
Pika Pika! Pika Pika! Soll ich jetzt sprechen.
Pika Pika! It's because...
It's because it's me, Pikachu!
What the fuck is this movie?
It's because I'm lactose intolerant.
Ash, I am your father.
Leute, was ist das?
It's because I'm gay. What the, Pikachu! I mean, it's okay, it's okay, but why the fuck does he speak? Nichts könnte er sagen. Und das auch ein bisschen freue ich mich deswegen auch auf den neuen Star Wars. Aber sorry, einfach nur
okay, der Film kam ganz gut ein,
der nächste Film fangen die Pokébälle anzusprechen.
Man kann alles in der Pokémon-Welt
sprechen. Die Pflanzen aber irgendwann.
Auch die Tiere, die normalen Tiere in der
Pokémon-Welt. Die es ja auch gibt,
bevor wir es vergessen.
Das sind normale Möwen, die da rumfliegen.
Wir müssen erstmal Antenne
Alabastia machen. Ja, klar. Zu Pokémon geht es noch einiges. Ich glaube, Antenne Alabastia war nicht Platz zwei. Nee, doch, ich meine schon. Antenne Alabastia. Ich glaube, Antenne Auland. War auch noch gut dabei. Ey, das wird die letzten zehn Folgen von Podcasts. Müssen wir noch mal alles durch. Das machen wir zur Herr-der-Ringe-Serie von Amazon. Können wir gerne machen. Ich finde lustig, wenn man was versucht, wenn man sich mal aus der Comfortzone bewegt und dann geht das schief. Das ist immer lustig. Man braucht auch einen Film, wenn man Leute, die haben Drive, die haben plötzlich eine Art von Charakterentwicklung und bewegen sich aus der Comfortzone raus und dann im echten Leben ist oft der Fall einfach, dass man sagt, gut, es misslingt und dann geht geht man wieder so ein War of Shame zurück. Zum Beispiel habe ich jetzt gehört, hat sich eine gute Freundin, hat sich ein Tattoo gestochen. Alle haben schon gesagt, nee, komm, lass es doch sein und so. Und sie auch, ja, ich weiß nicht genau. Und über Jahre ging das. Dann hat sie es endlich gemacht, endlich hat sie gesagt, okay, komm, ich will das gerne machen, ich lasse mir ein Tattoo stechen. Hinten am Knöchel, hinten an der Ferse, Ferse, Kn-Richtung. Und dann war die im Urlaub und ist da gewandert und gewandert und hat sich eine Blase gelaufen und dann war das Tattoo weg. What? Ja, hat sich genau an dem Tattoo eine Blase gelaufen und dann ist es, und dann ist irgendwann die Blase aufgegangen, wie wir das Blasen halt so machen und dann ist das Tattoo weg jetzt. Es ist halt was? Und ich stelle mir vor, erst mal gibt es viele Leute, die ihre Tattoos weghaben wollen, die beneiden. Sie wollte aber das Tattoo haben, war sich aber nicht so sicher, hat auch nicht mehr so richtig gefallen. Und dann geht sie, wann dann das Tattoo weg? Und ich mir denke, ja, gut, sie hat es versucht, okay? Sie hat es versucht, sie hat den Traum verwirklicht. Jetzt verloren. Es hat nicht sollen sein. Sie denkt sich auch, ich kann nicht zum selben Tattoo-Studio nochmal gehen. Was ist mit ihrem Tattoo passiert? Ich bin die Schwester. Ich bin die zwittige Schwester. Wir wollen das gleiche Tattoo haben. Aber es ist eine geniale Idee, wenn du dein Tattoo loshaben willst. Können sie sich vielleicht so eine Stunde lang so drauf reiben? Ja, einfach hier an dem Stuhl, einfach die ganze Zeit bewegen. Wir haben so einen Ganzkörperschuh. Kann man Blasen produzieren? Da kam schon die Antwort rein. Okay, die Antwort hier von Lea, sie schreibt nein, kann man nicht. Das fand ich so lustig. Einfach dieses, mach ich's, mach ich's nicht, mach ich's, mach ich nicht. Okay, ich mach's weg. Wie klein war das Tattoo denn, dass es... Ich glaube, es war nicht groß. Es muss sehr klein gewesen sein. So ein Herzchen, so Taube. Ich glaube, Sternchen, Herzchen, sowas. Ey, wie kann man denn über Jahre... Na gut, ich bin nicht in dem Mindset für Tattoo. Ich kann es einfach nicht verstehen. Und es ist auch okay, muss ich auch nicht verstehen können. Aber manchmal wird man auch Leute in seinem Umfeld beeindrucken. Ich denke mir zum Beispiel, wenn ich anfangen würde Warum dann Knöchel? Aber wenn ich morgen mit einem Tattoo käme, würde alle sagen, what, das hätte ich nicht erwartet. Und wir sind ja auch, als Leute, die Comedy machen, wollen wir auch immer Leute überraschen. Mein ganzes Leben begreife ich als grosse Feedline für den einen Tag, wo ich dann mit dem Gesichtstattoo komme oder mit Pfeife rauchend in die Firma komme. Ich will nicht zu nahe treten, aber ich glaube, du bist einer der Menschen, die, wenn sie ein Tattoo hätten, jeder sagen würde, ja, völlig klar. Er ist verzweifelt auf der Suche nach einer Persönlichkeit. Werden verzweifelt? Er ist verzweifelt auf der Suche nach einem USP, natürlich. Du bist der erste... USP? Ja, klar! Ich bin der Keksessende. Du bist der Typ, der sich eine Halbklasse rasiert mit seinen langen Haaren, nur damit er cool aussieht, damit er aussieht wie Max Landis und dann irgendwie so, oh, ich habe jetzt auch lange Haare. Ich bin genau so kreativ, ich habe auch lange Haare und eine Seite fehlt. Mach auch mittelmäßige Filme. Nee, alle wissen, dass ich der Typ bin, der Kekse isst, während er podcastet. Das sind zwei Arten von Kekse vor dir. Du hast einmal die Cookies, die knusprigen und dann die Jaffa-Cakes. Und Jaffa-Cakes sind schon ganz was Feines, muss man sagen. Probe doch mal. Nee, danke. Riecht man wenigstens dran. Ja, die riechen sehr gut. Sind die denn auch so ein bisschen zimtig? Oh, apropos zimt, oh, gut, dass du es sagst. Ah, wir haben eine mega Nachricht bekommen. Wir haben eine super Nachricht bekommen. Nee, ist kein Zimt dran bei mir. Wir haben eine tolle Nachricht bekommen von vielleicht einem der wichtigsten Menschen in der Podcast-Historie aller Zeiten, und zwar von einer Lebensmittelwissenschaftlerin, Lebensmittelforscherin. Ohne Scheiß, man muss sagen dazu, kurze Anmoderation, die Nachricht ist wahnsinnig lang und sehr informativ. Und ich dachte mir, und sie erklärt uns, warum Zimt eine Besonderheit ist, wenn man das isst und schmeckt. Und ich habe die ganze Zeit gedacht, ja, das ist Bullshit, das stimmt alles nicht, nee, der Punkt stimmt auch nicht, nope, das stimmt auch nicht. Nun hat sie gesagt, mit freundlichen Grüßen, die Lebensmittelwissenschaftlerin, weiß ich nicht mehr, wie sie hieß. Und ich mir auch dachte, okay, ich arrogantes Arschloch habe ihr die ganze Zeit gedanklich widersprochen, weil ich es einfach nicht für möglich gehalten habe, und dann unterschreibt sie als Lebensmittelfräucherin und ich habe gesagt, okay, ich war in allen Punkten gerade falsch, du hast offensichtlich doch recht, aber man ist so arrogant, wenn Leute was besser wüssten, als ich, würde ich das per se erstmal nicht akzeptieren. Ja, wir schauen ganz kurz rein, ich finde aber, wir haben hier sehr schlechtes Internet, was ich finde, was tatsächlich fehlt, ist so eine Anzeige, so ein gut gemeinter Rat, der dir deinen Computer gibt, so, hey, pass auf, ich verstehe, was du hier versuchst gerade zu machen, aber dafür ist das Internet schlicht zu schlecht gerade. So würde ich so, jemand, der dich mal zur Seite nimmt und so sagt, hey, nicht dieser Balken, der versucht. Genau, nicht dieses A und ein Ladebalken, sondern einfach so jemand, der sagt so, hey, pass auf, ich nehme mich mal ganz kurz zur Seite,
du willst jetzt gerade ein YouTube-Video angucken, das geht gerade nicht, okay, dafür ist jetzt einfach gerade nicht genug Internet da, du kannst jetzt eine Sekunde angucken und dann 30 Sekunden warten, aber ich sage dir hier mal unter uns, es funktioniert halt einfach nicht. Stattdessen sieht man einen Balken, der sagt, ich hab's, hab's gleich. Ja, und das ist einfach eine Lüge. Wait, ganz kurz. Gebt mir noch. Warte, ich bin, ich bewege mich. Bullshit. Ich bewege mich so langsam, dass man denken könnte, dieser blaue Balken ist stehen geblieben, aber ich bewege, hey, hey. Keine Verbindung, keine Verbindung. Vor allem, wenn das Internet so schlecht ist, dass du nicht mal eine Facebook-Seite aufrufen kannst. Oder, das ist halt so ein Plug-in für Chrome, dass alles, was du nicht anklicken kannst, rot ist.
Dass der genau checkt, wie viel
Internetverbindung du gerade hast und du sagst, okay,
Textdateien gehen, Bild,
nope, versuch's erst gar, versuch's nicht.
Das ist genau das, was ich will.
So ein roter Bildschirm, die ein Set vorher hinwürgt.
Und dann vor allem die Anzeige dann,
wenn man das versucht hat, zehn Minuten lang,
nicht, sie haben kein Internet, sondern die Anzeige, Verbindung zum Server fehlgeschlagen. Ja. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, das ist nicht der Begründung, warum das nicht funktioniert. Das Internet ist das Problem. Ich will, dass das Internet, dass der Computer dieses Versuchs erst gar nicht, Mindset hat. Weil frustrierend ist es ja erst, wenn du auf das Bild klickst und es lädt ewig nicht und du denkst dir, soll ich jetzt noch warten, soll ich jetzt auf mein Display starren oder nicht? Ja, es ist in einem Boot mit einem sein Gefühl. Richtig, es ist ein Vertrauensverhältnis. Wir sind eine Gruppe gerade, wir wollen das Gleiche. Auch ich will die Website anzeigen, ich kann nur gerade nicht. Ich will dir auch helfen. Mehr Ehrlichkeit vom Computer, der einfach das Bild einfach rot einfärbt, sodass er sagt, hey, klick hier gar nicht erst drauf. Und du sagst, okay, dann mache ich es halt auch nicht.
Wenn ich weiß, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ist es gerade rot, dann ärgere ich mich auch nicht, dass ich nicht über die Strasse kann, weil ich weiß, es ist rot. Und ich warte zu einem anderen Punkt. Manchmal geht man auch über rot. Ja, so, wir haben eine Nachricht bekommen von Heike, die schreibt, Zimt kann man nicht schmecken, sondern nur riechen. So, das war eine Ansage.
Ich hab das gelesen, ich stand da gerade irgendwie in der sondern nur riechen. Ich habe gesagt Bullshit! Das war eine Ansage.
Ich habe es gelesen, ich stand da gerade irgendwie in der U-Bahn und habe gerufen Bullshit!
Ja.
War eine dusselige Aussage. Ich dachte mir, das kann nicht ernst sein.
Also vor allem, erst heisst es Zunge, Zunge, Zunge. Man schmeckt mit der Zunge.
Dann heisst es Nase, Nase, Nase, Nase.
Eigentlich gibt es gar keine Schnecken mit der Zunge.
Eigentlich gibt es gar keine Nase.
Sondern es ist alles Nase und auf Zunge hat man nur bittersüß und dann wieder nein, Galileo Mystery. Auch das stimmt nicht. Ich dachte, Galileo hätte er rausgefunden. Heute noch, gestern. Auch das stimmt nicht. Aber auf jeden Fall, Heike hat es jetzt raus. Zimt kann man nicht schmecken, sondern nur riechen. Das könnt ihr ausprobieren, indem ihr was mit Zimtgeschmack esst und euch dabei die Nase zuhaltet. Halt, Halt, These. Ich habe das hier versucht. Ich bin gestern auf dem Weg zur Arbeit, habe ich mit ein Käsebrötchen gegessen und habe mir dann die Nase zugehalten. Unterbewusst. Es war wirklich keine bewusste Handlung. Ich habe mir die Nase zugehalten, weil ich das prüfen wollte und sehe dann auch so ein paar Passanten an mir vorbeilaufen, die sich dachten, was ist mit ihm jetzt falsch, warum hält er sich die Nase zu wählen, ein Käsebrötchen ist und man schmeckt auch nicht das Käsebrötchen. Meine These ist nämlich, wenn meine Nase zu ist, wenn ich krank bin, schmecke ich auch nichts mehr. Ja, das ist ja so das Ding, dass man sich... Warum sagt sie denn jetzt, dass man... Gut, das habe ich mir in Frage gestellt, aber sie unterschreibt als Lebensmittelforscherin. Ist das ein Scherz? Also ich glaube, wir haben ja letztes Mal schon angesprochen, dass sich Zimt nicht mit Wasser vermischt. Und im Mund ist ja Speichelgegend, Speichel ist ja König im Mund. Und alles, was sich nicht mit dem Speichel verbindet, schmeckt es. Ich glaube, wenn du zum Beispiel auch einen ganz trockenen Mund hast, schmeckst du nichts, weil deine Geschmacksnerven die Verbindung mit dem Speichel brauchen. Und Zimt verbindet sich schlicht nicht mit Flüssigkeit. Never. Und andere Sachen schon. Zucker zum Beispiel, das passt. Und Vanille, wie wir lernen. So, und jetzt geht es nämlich weiter. Bei Vanille hingegen reicht schon eine Mini-Mini-Menge, um etwas zu schmecken. Forscherinnen sagen nicht Mini-Mini-Menge. Schwäne. Ja, aber das ist jetzt Forscherin spricht, die mit Vierjährigen spricht, okay? Ja, das stimmt. Die Sprache orientiert sich auch am Adressaten. Hey, ihr beiden! Ich glaube, da muss man auch eher diese Mail vorlesen. Ja, auch dieses Hände auf den Knien so ein bisschen nach unten gebeugt.
Genau, auch wieder dieses, wir brauchen ein bisschen länger noch.
Hey, ihr beiden, also, das sind mini, mini, mini, mini, ganz winzig, klein, winzig kleine Männchen.
Aber dann hat sie noch den Fachbegriff Schwellenwert hinzugefügt.
Deshalb kann man einfach das Innere einer Schote in Milch tun und schon hat man eine Vanillemilch.
Hinter den kleinen Punkten steckt
ordentlich Wumms. Ich hoffe, ich konnte euch helfen.
Auf jeden Fall, Heike, und das würde ich jetzt gerne auch ausprobieren.
Vanilleschote, kratzt das mal aus
von Hauz in Milch. Kann man so einfach
Vanillemilch machen? Ich esse jetzt diesen
Jaffa Cake mit Pflaume.
Und hält sie die Nase zu. Und der hat einen sehr intensiven Geschmack,
eigentlich. Ich hab mal kurz die Nase zu, okay?
Okay.
Geh mal ein bisschen näher aus mir.
Geschmacksexperiment Stefan Tee. Ich schmecke nichts. Ich schmecke absolut nichts. Ich kann nicht mehr stucken. Aber du schmeckst schon, dass es süss ist, oder? Nein. Du schmeckst gar nichts? Nein. Ach komm. Nein. Stefan. Bisschen süss. Strenge dich an. Jetzt habe ich dich aufgemacht und ich schmecke sofort. Das ist echt interessant, ey. Man kann nicht... Aber ich verstehe nicht, weil die Luft ist doch noch... Wie hieß die nochmal? Heike? Heike, ja. Heike. Was kann man denn schmecken, wenn man die Nase sich zuhält? Vanille anscheinend. Weil sie sagt ja eben Vanille hingegen. Hat einen größeren Schwellenwert. Also vielleicht ist das nicht was, was sie meint.
Sollen wir so eine Tabelle machen?
Wenn der ganz hohe Schwellenwert Vanille ist und ganz unten zimmt, dann soll sie mal aufschreiben, was da zwischen alles ist.
Vor allem, wenn du Jaffa Cake isst, dann isst doch die Jaffa Cake Luft in deiner Nase.
Und wenn du die Nase zudrückst, ist die Luft doch immer noch in deiner Nase.
Die Luft ist egal.
Ja, aber der Geruch wird doch über Luft vermittelt. Der Geruch ist egal. Ja, Moment. Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, Ich glaube, wir sind am Tiefpunkt. Was gerade geschehen ist, ist, Florentin Will sagt, Nase ist Geruch. Aber Nase ist doch Geruch. Und Stefan Tietze fällt sein angebissener Duffer Cake runter. Das ist gerade passiert. Wir sind offiziell drei Jahre alt. Das ist passiert. Nase ist doch Geruch. 23. November 2017, 17.10 Uhr, Nase ist Geruch, Duffer Cake fällt runter. Das ist, wow, zwei erwachsene Männer sitzen sich gegenüber. Männer? Würdest du dich als Mann bezeichnen auch? Ich bin ein kleiner Junge, im Körper eines Tages. Nee, ich habe letztens jemandem gegenüber gesagt, da sind Erwachsene im Haus und habe mich selbst nicht als Erwachsen bezeichnet. Würde ich auch nicht. Wir erkunden unseren Körper heute. Ey, wir entdecken, mach mal die Hose auf. Aber sorry, du hast gerade gesagt, dass es beim Schmecken durch die Nase nicht um Luft und nicht um Geruch geht. Jetzt ist meine Frage, worum geht es denn dann? Kommt Speichel in die Nase durch den Mund oder wodurch überträgt sich die Information, wenn nicht durch Luft? Also ich glaube, Geschmack ist nicht in der Luft, sondern in den kleinen ähm, ja, jetzt
hiebe das Wort, ich nenne es mal Molekülen,
die da so rumschwirren.
Und die bleiben, glaube ich,
und die bleiben dann kleben, auf etwas.
Kleben? Im Nasen-Rachen-Raum.
Ja, aber dann noch nicht in der Nase.
Auch in der Nase. Ich glaube, Nase kann das
dann erst quasi lesen.
Nein, aber wenn du sagst, man schmeckt in der Nase, dann implizierst du eine Trennung zwischen den Organen Nase und Organ Mund. Und du kannst es nicht einfach sagen, das bleibt im Mund hängen und deswegen Nase. Es heißt Hals, Nasen, Ohren, Arzt. Ja, aber trotzdem sind es unterschiedliche Organe. Das ist ein grosser Raum, den man als Einheit betrachten muss. Nein! Der zusammen andere Aufgaben hat, gut, aber halt insgesamt zusammenarbeitet. Und ich glaube, dass du einfach das ganze System blockierst, wenn du die Nase zumachst. Ich glaube, das ist schon eine Aufgabenverteilung, aber das ist wie, als ob du dann einfach den Ausknopf drückst. Also du meinst, dass du sozusagen hintenrum, also vornerum wäre jetzt durch die Nasenlöcher, und dass da hintenrum noch mal was kommt. Gut, wir können den Tester weitermachen, die Versuche gehen weiter. Ich halte nur meine Nasenlöcher zu, okay? Wobei, man kann doch was essen, ohne es zu riechen. Innen drinnen riechen, meinst du jetzt? Man riecht es von innen oder was? Nein, ich dachte, man riecht es von außen. Ich weiß nicht, was das extra mir jetzt bringen soll. Stefan hat sich die Finger in die Nasenlöcher gesteckt und isst jetzt ein Java Cake.ake. Was soll das bringen? Ich rieche ihn nicht, okay? Ich halte mir meine Nase zu, bis ich ihn esse. So, ich habe nicht gerochen. Und jetzt fange ich erst an, wieder zu riechen. Und trotzdem schmecke ich es. Ja, weil durch den Mund kommt da was raus. Nein, aber ... Die Hunde können Sachen durch Wände riechen, ey! Du glaubst nicht, dass es da interessiert, ob da dein Mut zu ist oder nicht. Unsere Nase ist doch beschissen. Von innen kommt das. Aber was genau wird denn jetzt verändert, wenn du dir die Nase zudrückst? Die Nase an sich, wenn du was riechst, dann ist doch die Rezeptoren sind noch nicht direkt in den Nasenlöchern, sondern irgendwo da hinten, so auf Augenhöhe oder sowas. So, okay, ich hab meine Nase zu, okay? Ja. Meine Nase zugehalten. Langsam werde ich fett, wenn mich das Experiment nervt. So, ich hab meine Nase zu, jetzt nehme ich den Jaffa Cake. Eifel ihn. Ja? So. Jetzt gehe ich weg von, ich habe aufzusprechen, ich habe aufzusprechen und gehe jetzt weg von Jaffa Cakes, den anderen Jaffa Cake. Aua, Aua. So, und jetzt?
Ich spreche dir einfach ein Abbruch.
Ey, bevor du entstickst, das ist es nicht wert.
Sofort den Geschmack.
Oh Mann, ey, so stelle ich mir die Arbeit eines eines Lebensmittelforscherin von Heike vor. Können wir abbrechen. Was ist jetzt gerade passiert? Du hast versucht gleichzeitig zu atmen und dir die Nase zuzuhalten. Nein, ich musste lachen und dann hätte ich diesen Jaffa-Cake in meinen Rachenraum bekommen. Aber ich konnte auch nicht wirklich was dagegen tun, wenn meine Nase zu war. So, Versuch ist uneindeutig ausgegangen. Nein, tatsächlich habe ich bestätigt dadurch, ich habe es erwiesen, dass der Geruch von innen kommen muss. Ja, das ist trotzdem Geruch. Gut, aber durch die Luft, es ging mir um die Luft,
dass es über die Luft übertragen wird.
Heike, kannst du uns bitte mal eine Nummer mitteilen?
Oder möchtest du mal in unserem Podcast kommen?
Weil wir haben auch, Essen war schon die ganze Zeit
irgendwie so ein bisschen überschwängliches Thema,
unterschwellig, und deswegen sollten wir auch mal
mit den ganzen Geheimnissen.
Wir haben mal gefragt, was ist, wenn man nur Geschmacksverstärker isst?
Wonach schmeckt das dann?
Sein Speichel, da kann man seinen eigenen Speichel schmecken. So, und das sind alles Fragen von der ersten Frage bis zu der Frage, die wir uns jetzt gestellt haben. Möchte ich gerne wissen, was... Viel Spaß mit weiteren 20 Minuten Stefan umluftringend Tietze. Bin ich ein bisschen blau geworden auch? Pflaumig geworden im Gesicht.
Und deswegen haben wir auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Fragen, die da in der Hinsicht beantwortet werden müssen.
Bis dahin gönnt euch eine schöne Vanillemilch.
Einfach das Innere einer Vanilleschote auskratzen.
Bourbon Vanille, was auch immer Bourbon heißen soll. Ja, Vanille, was ist das denn für ein Scheiß?
Vanille?
Vanille, ja.
Der Spanier sagt?
Ja, aber es ist ja kein spanisches Wort, oder? Vanille, Vanille. Das ist ja so nicht Paella. Ja, aber Paella ist ja ein spanisches Wort, wie Mallorca. Man sagt doch nicht Mallorca. Warum sagt man manchmal Paella und Mallorca nicht? Aber ist Vanille denn ein spanisches Wort? Nein. Ich habe jetzt schon Bock auf Vanille. Kann man echt so einfach Vanille in Milch an? Warum trinkt man überhaupt noch normale Milch, wenn man einfach auch Vanille Milch trinkt? Das Phänomen Milch hat sich mir eh nie erschlossen. Nur weil es eine andere Konsistenz hat. Es ist ähnlich geschmacksneutral wie Wasser. Bitte was? Es ist schon Milch ist geschmacksneutral. Stefan, ich breche hier an der Stelle ab. Nee, deswegen mischt man ja auch mit Kakao. Du kannst nicht sagen, Milch schmeckt wie Wasser. Nein, das Tümpf, du bist unfassbar. Ich habe gesagt, es ist ähnlich geschmacksneutral. Es hat ähnlich wenig Wumms. Wie, um in dem mittelfahrs Sprache zu sprechen, hat es wenig Wumms. Milch schmeckt doch noch was. Es hat Flutin. Es hat einen Mini-Mini-Mini-Schmellen. Haarmilch schmeckt doch anders als Milch. Natürlich, ein bisschen. Aber es ist doch nicht so geschmacksintensiv wie andere. Das ist doch eine gewisse Default-Flüssigkeit. Allein durch deine Säugetier-Vergangenheit ist es doch eine Art Default-Flüssigkeit, die du zunehmst. Das hat doch nicht keinen großen Geschmack. Es ist natürlich schwierig Geschmacksintensität. Deswegen wird er auch andauernd gemischt. Dinge mit wenig Geschmack werden andauernd gemischt. Mit Vanille, mit Erdbeer, werden zu Joghurt mit verschiedenen Bullshit verwendet, Kakao, Wasser wird auch noch Geschmack.
Ja, aber es gibt auch Cherry Coke und Coke ist auch geschmacksintensiv.
Deswegen Wasser ja geschmacksintensiv. Deswegen wird das zu Cola und Apfelschorle.
Aber es gibt in Deutschland keine Vanille-Cornflakes, weil ich habe gerade versucht, Vanillemilch weiterzudenken mit Cornflakes.
In Amerika glaube ich schon, da gibt es dann so, ich glaub Bienchen sind das auch, nee, das wäre dann wieder Honig, ne, es gibt keinen Vanille-Cornflakes. Ja, die Bienchen machen Honig, Florentin, die Bienchen. Oh, ich würd so gerne mal wieder Snacks. Eigentlich habe ich gelernt für gute Arbeit von Sketch, dass auch die Bienen, dass auch Bienen sind sehr, sehr wichtig für die Umwelt, klar wissen ja alle, deswegen wollen die auch alle retten, Wespen sind ähnlich wichtig für die Umwelt, Wespen sind nämlich noch robuster und stärker als Bienen und sind ähnlich daran beteiligt, die Pflanzen zu bestäuben. Hat jetzt nicht irgend so ein Schauspieler so ganz viel Land gekauft und da ganz viel Bienen angesiedelt? Ich weiss nicht, wer es war, irgendjemand, der gesagt hat ... Für die Arbeiten von The Bee Movie meinst du? Nee, ich glaube, jemand, der einfach ... Ja, einfach jemand, der gesagt hat, ich nehme das jetzt einfach in die eigene Hand, ich rette jetzt eigenhändig Bienen. Ich rette jetzt eigenhändig einen Hektar. Und kauft mir einfach ... Wie groß ist ein Hektar? Stell dir mal einen Hektar jetzt vor, vor deinem inneren Auge.
Ist Hektar das mit der A? Also was denn nochmal? Ja, A ist Fläche auch, aber A, ich weiß, was du meinst. Also A ist einmal Ja für Anus und dann nochmal Hektar ist H A, ist Hektar, nee Hektometer, Hektometer. hahaha, hahaha, ein halber Hektar. Nee, Hektometer. Hektometer. Ha, ha, ha. Ha, ha, ha. Ein halber Hektoliter. Hektoliter Ha-Milch. Ha, ha, ha, Liter. Okay, what? Alle Podcast-Hurhörer sind zu Hause. Wie als Fankt-Pakatsch an zu sprechen. What the what? Was ist grösser, ein Quadratkilometer oder ein Hektar? Zehn Hektar. Zehn Hektar sind ein Quadratkilometer? Ne, sind so gross wie, sind grösser als. Ja? Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe echt keine Ahnung. Ich habe wirklich nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung, wie gross ein Hektar ist. Hektar sind doch zehn mal zehn, ein hundert Quadratkilometer, oder? Hm, nee. Das ist schon richtig gross. Das wäre riesig, ne? Nee, das kann nicht sein. Jedenfalls Hornissen ähnlich. Hornissen, Wespen und Bienen sind alle gleich wichtig. Ja, nee. Hummeln, Problem ist, dass Hornissen auch Bienen essen. So, und dann fängt es für mich an, dass es kompliziert wird. Weil Hornissen darfst du nicht töten, weil halten das Ökosystem beieinander. Sind sie aber jetzt wichtiger als Bienen, heißt, sollte man lieber eine Hornisse retten und die Gefahr eingehen, dass sie auch mal eine Bienen tötet? Wie viele Bienen töteten Hornisse pro Jahr? Ja, aber vor allem, wenn du jetzt dafür sorgst, dass es mehr Bienen gibt, gibt es automatisch auch mehr Hornissen, weil die mehr zu essen kriegen und sich mehr vermehren. Du kannst die gar nicht trennen, die Bestände, weil die immer sich anpassen. In meinem Leben bin ich auf der Suche nach Antworten und je mehr Antworten ich näher komme, desto mehr Fragen bilden sich. Hummeln? Ja, Hummeln machen auch, bestäuben auch. Bremsen? Nee, Bremsen, hör auf, ey.
Sind Pferde fliegen,
Bremsen? Ich wette, in 100 Jahren sind alle ausgestorben und es gibt so arme
Menschen, die immer so Blumen anlecken
müssen, die dann irgendwie so durch die
Wälder laufen und so das alles
anlecken und dann so persönlich die
bestäuben müssen. Da kommt so eine große
Fließbänder, wo so Gänseblümchen drauf sind. Und du hältst da deine Zunge raus. Ja, das ist deine Arbeit. Und dann kommst du nach Hause mit so einer schlaffen Zunge. Hallo, Thud. Ja, so wie Bart Simpson, der ja ganz viele Briefumschläge anlecken musste. Und ich musste in meinem Callcenter auch mal, da habe ich einen ganzen Stabel Briefumschläge bekommen und ganz viele Zettel und musste sich die alle anlecken und auch zumachen. Da dachte ich mir, genau wie Bart Simpson. Ich bin wie Bart Simpson. Ich bin wie Bart Simpson. Da hat mich echt durch den Tag gebracht. Ich glaube, rückblickend, dass der Tafelwitz des Simpsons mich zur Comedy gebracht hat. Ja? Weil die Tafelgags, die haben eine ganz coole Dynamik. Und zwar sind es ja keine Witze. Er schreibt ja keine Witze an die Tafel. Er schreibt Sätze an die Tafel. Also du meinst ganz gut im Simpsons Intro, wo man immer sieht, dass Bart gerade Nachsitzen macht und immer wieder denselben Satz an die Tafel schreibt und dann hört die Klingel. Wenn er diese Erklärung braucht, um das zu verstehen, dann ist der Podcast auch nicht richtig für euch. Ich versuche, möglichst viele Leute ins Boot zu holen. Nee, finde ich gut. Ich sage nur, dass wir diese Leute nicht brauchen. So, und da steht immer was anderes drin, nämlich, ich soll nicht dem Rektor sagen, dass Freitag der 13. mein Geburtstag ist. Genau. Und das Coole daran ist, nicht die Witze, sondern die Welt, die es aufmacht. Das ist eine ganz spezielle Dynamik. Der Kontext ist nämlich der Gag. Der Kontext ist, an die Tafel schreiben zu müssen, und zwar dahinter steckt ja die Geschichte dahinter, dass es Leute aufgeregt haben muss, die Leute neben ihm saßen, dass er erwischt wurde, dass der Rektor das auf sich bezogen hat, da ist immer eine Geschichte dahinter, allein der Kontext ist der Gag. Das ist nie der Witz, das ist nie lustig für sich genommen, was auf der Tafel steht. Manchmal auch, klar. Aber das Gesamtkunstwerk, dass dahinter, dass es in einem Satz nur allein durch den Kontext so viel Geschichte und so viel Kopfkino aufgemacht wird, dass du darüber theoretisch in deinem Kopf so eine kleine Simpsons-Folge ablaufen hast. Wo ich mir denke, wow, wenig Wörter. Beziehen die sich eigentlich manchmal auf andere Folgen? Kann gut sein, weiß ich nicht genau. In jedem Intro haben die einmal den Tafelgag und den Couchgag. Also der Hardcore-Halligalli-Effekt, dass du dir in jeder Folge was Neues überlegen musst. Dann einfach, du brauchst für jeden Couchgag. Die waren auch nie wirklich lustig. Das ist ein Simpsons-Phänomen mit dem Halligalli-Gag-Phänomen beschreiben und umgekehrt. Ja, aber das stimmt natürlich. Das ist wirklich interessant. Der Couchgag ist genau ein Gegenbeispiel also das ist ein Witz, der ja auch funktioniert, aber ganz anders, also der, der muss zu erklären, das muss ein Witz für sich sein oder eine lustige Slapstick irgendwo was. Slapstick-Sache, genau, aber das fand ich immer toll und dann dachte ich mir, wow, du kannst mit wenigen Feitern in dem Kopf deines Gegenübers einfach die Welt zum Einsturz bringen oder in eine ganz andere Richtung lenken.
Und das fand ich toll.
Und das hat kleinen Stefan, der sich gerade die Nase zugehalten hat,
dazu bewogen zu sagen.
Genau. Ich will auch mal.
Ich will professionell Jaffa-Cakes essen und mir dabei die Nase zuhalten.
Jaffa-Cake oder Oreo?
Äh, Jaffa-Cake.
Oreo oder 100 Dollar?
100 Dollar, ob ich jetzt...
Okay. Jetzt bist du wieder dran. Äaffa Cake oder Cookie? Cookie. Oh, es regnet? Oh, was das für eine Atmosphäre ist, ne? Wenn es so ein bisschen gegen die Scheibe dröppelt. Das finde ich ganz interessant. Mache ich mir manchmal an, wenn ich was lese oder so, mach ich mir an, so YouTube, so Rain Against Window, das finde ich, ist eine ganz angenehme Atmosphäre. Machst du aus, wenn das Lied an. This is the rain against the window. Africa. You can take a love to take me away from you. Hallo, hier ist Gema. Hör mal auf zu singen jetzt, hier ist Gema. Ist ihr Name Gema? Ja, wenn du neben der Gema wohnst, wie nervig muss das denn? Guck mal, das ist ein Sitcom, mein Leben neben der Gema und dann jedes Mal Happy Birthday to... Hey, hier ist Gema. Gema woanders hin. Hör auf jetzt. Guck mal, das ist der Heizspender, der früher auch immer in unserem... Heizspender? Du kannst Wärme spenden, du kannst nicht Hitze spenden. Wow. Und mit diesem Wort verabschiedet sich Stefan Dietze von der heutigen Ausgabe. Wow, okay, hast du mich abmoderiert? Du machst noch weiter. Wir haben viele... Verabschiedet sich Stefan Dietze. Ja, wir haben viele Fragen aufgemacht in dieser Folge. Und noch wenige Antworten. Wir werden wahrscheinlich wieder viele hilfreiche, aber auch nervige Zuschriften bekommen. Ich freue mich auf ganz viele Bilder von Vanillemilch, die alle genau so aussehen wie normale Milch. Und viele davon sind debatable, stock-footed. Und jetzt wieso, ey, eh nicht so spannend sind. Stellt euch vor jedem Bild, was ihr hochhört, die Frage.
Braucht es die Welt?
Und wir sehen das, wenn ihr Stockfootage in eure Hand schockt.
Wir sehen das Wasserzeichen.
Wir sehen das, wenn ihr nicht wirklich Vanillemilch kocht, sondern das nur rein schockt.
Wir bemerken das.
Ja?
Versucht es erst gar nicht.
Und jetzt kommen die ganzen Stockfootage-Bilder ironisch zu uns.
Ha, ha, ha.
Weiss nicht, was wir machen.
Doppelt ironisch immer einmal.
Macht's gut, das war Stefan T.
Das war Florentin B.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Versucht's erst gar nicht. Und jetzt kommen die ganzen Stockfugelspieler ironisch zu uns. Ha ha ha, doppelt ironisch immer einmal.
Macht's gut, das war Stefan T.
Das war Florentin B.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, wenn es wieder heisst.
Ciao.